hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown Confederate
statues are coming down all over the
country and some say a good chunk of
history is going with them
Fox News Sunday anchor Chris Wallace
weighs in on this controversy former
national security adviser John Bolton's
new book and why he thinks presumptive
Democratic nominee Joe Biden continues
to lead President Trump in the polls
also coronavirus cases in the u.s.
continue to rise Missouri governor Mike
parson defends his decision for
reopening the state when he did and
discusses how he's addressing the
region's uptick in infections Plus
commentary from host of Fox Across
America
Jimmy fela the Fox News rundown is a
Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to Fox News
podcast.com I'm Sandra Smith I'm Brett
bear
I means lay your heart and this is the
Fox News rundown
Friday June 26 2020 I'm Chris foster
protests against racism and police
violence have now evolved into statues
being torn down in some places some of
them Confederate monuments some not
boxes Sunday host chris wallace is take
you can argue about public maybe they
should be put in from museums and not
just sort of thrown on the ash even
broke them off i can certainly
understand some of these patches being
offensive to people some of them i don't
understand why they were offensive i'm
jessica Rosenthal many state leaders are
on defense over increasing virus case
numbers while at the same time saying
they were expected and a lot of the
criticism is getting political for 90
days during the corona virus I have did
nothing but try to be the best governor
I could be in my state I didn't bring
the political side into this at all and
I'm Jimmy's family I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
Joe Biden is beating president Trump by
double digits in most national polls as
part of that a majority of Americans say
the president's doing a bad job dealing
with the corona virus outbreak President
Trump tells students supporters at a
rally in Phoenix Arizona one of the
states being hit hard now that the
plague is going away it's got all
different names wuhan kau Hans was
catching on coronavirus right cun flu
[Applause]
coronavirus cases are up in more States
than not with serious spikes and some
this week we had more cases in a single
day there was 38,000 we had at the
height of the pandemic in New York and
New Jersey Chris Wallace is the host of
Fox News Sunday I mean there was a real
surge and this is not a second wave this
is the first wave hitting a lot of the
Sun Belt states like Arizona and Texas
in Florida and and raising serious
questions and you start to see the
states that were at first the victims in
a pandemic like New York and New Jersey
and Connecticut they're not talking
about putting in a rule that if you come
from a hotspot state
you got a self quarantine for 14 days
before you can get out on the street so
everything is flipped around and we all
and you know you had
Anthony foundry dr. Falchi talking to a
congressional committee this week and
saying that you know this is a very
troublesome surge and he's very worried
about the months two weeks yeah
president Trump isn't really talking too
much about it he seems to be very
interested in protecting heritage and
monuments it seems that the police
protests have now turned into something
of a culture war do you think the
Confederacy's over yeah I you know it's
a it's an interesting question about
these statues I you know I remember when
the when the Soviet Union collapsed in
the early 90s and suddenly people were
taking down statues of Lenin and Marx
and you know on the one hand I
understood it and I understood that a
lot of people go to was a blob on
Russian history on the other hand it was
part of Russian history and you know you
can argue about whether they should be
in if they shouldn't be up in public
maybe they should be put in from museums
and not just sort of thrown on the ash
heap and broken off I can certainly
understand some of these statutes being
offensive to people some of them I don't
understand why they're offensive but but
again they're just part of our heritage
and if they're going to take them down
and I don't think the answer I never
think the answer is mob rule
there's a statue an Emancipation statue
of Lincoln and in Washington and they're
talking about taking that down this week
and you know congresswoman elliott
eleanor holmes norton was the
congresswoman for washington says no we
should we should put it in a museum so
it's the subject of study because it is
part of the whole I don't know it's a
interesting time to be alive in America
well yeah and then things are open to
interpretation its art the Lincoln
statue that you're talking about there
could be interpreted as an emancipated
slave looking subservient that wasn't
the intention that same thing with this
Teddy Roosevelt statue at the Natural
History Museum in New York City where
he's he's high up on a horse flanked by
a Native American and an African below
him and some people are interpreting
that in a way that I don't think it was
actually intended when the design was
there okay but on the other hand let me
just quickly say I mean I used to live
near the Museum of Natural History in
New York and Central Park was I don't
know if that if that statue was up back
then or not
I never particularly paid any attention
to it if I were a young african-american
today and I went and I saw this white
Savior on horseback in this subservient
looking African or African American at
his at his feet I would I wouldn't want
that I would I you know again I'm not
saying it should be torn down and
certainly not torn down by violence but
I can understand you know remove it and
put up a different statue of Teddy
Roosevelt so there are legitimate
conversations and interesting
conversations about our culture and our
history and what role things should have
I obviously I don't ever think that mob
violence is the way to solve them 130
days out now from the presidential
election Joe Biden's up more and more it
seems every week not just double digits
in the national polls but maybe more
importantly in the battleground polls is
there something that President Trump
asked for more debates not fewer when
months ago he was talking about not
doing debates at all
yeah that's that's that's a giveaway you
don't keep saying these polls on aren't
accurate they're accurate and you know
that's that's a giveaway that you know
if when you say I want more debates that
means you're behind and if you're really
far ahead you don't want any debates at
all there's no question the president is
behind is behind nationally and as you
say he's fine I mean you had a Fox poll
last week that showed the president
behind by 12 points 52 38 and I have to
say I not sure I believed it you know
that seemed just extraordinary and now
you have a New York Times though which
ratifies it is behind actually by 14
points not 12 52 36 I don't think
there's any question that the
president's handling of Georgia flawed
and the police and-and-and the protests
/ riots has not stopped well with the
American people that they've seen him as
a figure of many people most people have
seen him as a figure of division not a
figure that's bringing the country
together and that's what you're seeing
in the polls right now after this farce
attendance in Tulsa now is the campaign
gonna have to rethink big events like
that for safety's sake and for
embarrassment sake well yeah that was an
embarrassment and and primarily I mean
you could argue well 6 8 10 whatever it
was thousand people in the middle of a
pandemic is a good crowd it's not a good
crowd when your own campaign says that a
million people want to come in and we're
going to have an overflow stage outdoors
because so many people aren't even going
to be able to get into the 20 thousand
seat arena you know you one of the keys
to politics is you got to set
expectations and you know if you've got
a crowd of 100 you need a room that fits
95 so it's overflowing and if you have a
room for 200 you're gonna take the head
which is you have a room that's half
empty so you know it's interesting
because there does seem to be some some
facts we're learning about this virus
and one of them seems to be because
you're not seeing a spike in people and
there were obviously tens of thousands
of people in various protests around the
country there doesn't seem to be any
spike from that outdoors does not seem
as dangerous
as indoors so you know I don't know the
lesson to me would be if you're gonna
hold a big mass event you hold it the
stadium you don't old it an inside arena
yeah highly recommend the outside versus
inside I spent a few days the beach and
it was blessedly normal feeling for a
while it just seemed like the virus
wasn't even out there now Chris as as I
predicted we're now calling you
best-selling author Chris Wallace
congratulations last weekend was
Father's Day looks like the book
released timing paid off we're talking
about countdown at 1945 how's it still
selling up adolphus shelves well thank
you for mentioning that Chris yeah I
mean the first week it was out it was
the best-selling hardcover book in
America either fiction or nonfiction and
we just got word that it's number two on
the New York Times list the second week
and that's one of the things I gather
are now learning a little bit about all
this that you know does it have legs is
it just he did some publicity and you
know there were a lot of pre-orders and
so you did well and I have to say you
know I've been in in television for for
a half a century and I've been lucky
enough to get some awards and stuff but
best-selling author is absolutely new to
me and I am tickled pink I am I just
could not be more proud and pleased by
it and and and what I really like and
for folks who want to get it is that
they seem to have received it the way
that that I wrote it which is a history
thriller people you know say I was up
all night reading it and it was a
page-turner and I couldn't be happier
about that
countdown 1945 116 days that changed the
world not a page-turner according to you
I have not received my copy out I've got
one floating around somewhere you said
John you know it is available at Amazon
and Barnes and Noble and just like that
your book yes
no no thanks oh you know you're coming
to the nipper no I've read I have read
your book I greatly enjoyed your book
I'm talking about the John Bolton book
which are you I got a copy of it and
I've been reading it I shouldn't say
this it is a bore I mean it's like he
just discard his diary so you've
literally you'll be reading
eleven o'clock on this day I have this
meeting with these people and at twelve
o'clock I have this meeting with these
people and you know sometimes the
meeting is really interesting and
sometimes the meeting did nothing and
there just seems to have been no editing
to say well let's forget the meeting at
eleven that didn't accomplish anything
so you find yourself skimming through
the book to find the good stuff and
there is some good stuff there's some
interesting stuff but boy you got to
wade through it so well do you see how
it does I mean I get her you know with
all the publicity it's gonna it's gonna
do very well for a couple of weeks but I
wonder if of it how it'll do three weeks
four weeks from now well it's a fine
line did he give away the milk for free
with with all the publicity do we know
all the good stuff well no that's right
you know and now I think that's happens
with a lot of these travel books you
read the story in The New York Times or
The Washington Post yes I know okay I
just saved myself 30 bucks right Chris
Wallace host of Fox News Sunday and
author of the aforementioned account
town 1945 Chris thanks a lot Kentucky
yes I forgot yes you did read it yes you
praised me and I apologize for that
Chris and yes it is available in
bookstores and online go get it
Thanks thank you Chris
this is Jimmy fella with your Fox News
commentary coming up some of the
criticism over increasing virus cases
has become political I know you're
shocked right Thursday New York's
Democratic Governor Andrew Cuomo
commented on CNN how Republican
governors have handled reopening namely
how the tables have turned
where Florida once told visiting New
Yorkers they had to quarantine for two
weeks now New Yorkers are telling
incoming Floridians to hunker down for
14 days you play politics with this
virus and you lost you told the people
of your state and you told the people of
this country White House don't worry
about it
just open up go about your business this
is all democratic hyperbole all really
now you see 27 states with the numbers
going up some have pointed out that many
of the states that are experiencing an
increase in cases now are led by
Republicans but here in California about
as blue of a state as you can get we are
also experiencing a rise Wednesday we
saw the highest number of cases reported
so far more than 7,100 hospitalizations
and ICU admissions increased as well but
the state's Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom says it was to some extent
expected but stay at home orders social
distancing and orders to wear masks
bought the state time to increase
hospital bed capacity and as a
consequence because of the interventions
here in the state of California we were
able to mitigate that curve and we never
experienced that sharp increase but what
we did do is we pushed out because of
these innovations the growth of that
curve but more modestly now one of those
republican-led states with increasing
cases is Missouri where restrictions on
businesses were lifted this month our
case count on the positive side went up
in the state but again nothing we wasn't
expecting to happen Mike parson is the
governor of Missouri because really what
we were doing a month ago on the test
count we probably tripled our testing
capability we were doing now 12 13
thousand tests a day so we were
expecting to find more positive cases I
think this is so important when you look
at that number you also have to look at
the hospitalization
I see used a ventilator all of that and
our hospitalization is steady it's been
going down so we're we're we feel like
we're well capable to handle any
situation and we're going to have areas
that spike clear with us a meat
processing plants here in the state
we've had some problems with but again
we know kind of how to target those
areas now and do the strategy to box
them in pretty quick same way up nursing
home so I think everybody that really
was trying to make it better every day
no sir I was a lot more prepared how to
handle these incidents when you have
these little breakout incidents across
your state let me ask you what is your
strategy because there there's been a
lot of different reports coming out of
Missouri about how you guys are handling
it some criticisms and questions you've
said like your attitude is more about
individualism you do things as you see
fit
wear a mask if you see fit and you've
also correct me if I'm wrong you've said
we're not going backwards we've reopened
and you don't foresee a situation in
which you shut things back down again
but is there some nuance here you're
saying nursing homes you're saying
meatpacking plants that you that you do
have some sort of strategy to address
things if they crop up or get worse in
certain areas I think the strategy were
doing we're on the nursing home tickler
we're now going in there now with a
whole new testing strategy we wouldn't
use him 60 days ago 90 days ago we were
testing employees to the multiple tests
were testing everybody where before you
wasn't doing that and then really
stepping up the contact tracing which we
know is a huge part of it but I know I
don't look think that where we're going
to shut the state down we're going to go
backwards here at all I think the
reality of it is this virus is here it's
going to be here until we find a vaccine
or till we find out a solution how to
fight it but for right now you have to
do both and the other thing is I think
what's important is when I talk about
self responsibility you know people here
and whether it's in Missouri or others
you got to know what your own
responsibilities are you got a no fear
in them high risk categories and if you
are don't put yourself in that any more
risk and you have to be and I think
people here understood that message it
seems like though we're reaching new
total highs each day and and we have the
most people who've died though from the
virus of any country so I know but
everybody says we'll look at the the
testing rate we're testing so many
people so of course we're gonna have
more positives right but I want your
thoughts on why so many people have died
in the u.s. we're at more than a hundred
and twenty-two thousand and you know I'm
hearing from some people some of my
friends and people in my life they're
they're sort of outraged at this and you
know they point to like a country like
Japan and they say look that's not a
small country they have a hundred and
twenty million people and under a
thousand deaths everybody wears masks
there what went wrong here in the United
States that we have so many people who
have died from this virus in three
months well I think first of all
oh no way there's nobody wants people to
die from a virus it doesn't matter what
the virus is I mean people just don't
want that to happen I think when it
first come here to this country I think
we all know that we wasn't prepared for
that as we should have been and I think
that's one thing that has the early on
it got it somewhat did almost get out of
control across the United States because
we just didn't know I mean I think as a
governor on the one of the ways that I
like to look at it now now that I have
information kind of armchair
quarterbacking here a little bit but I'm
trying to first when it's really come
out you're trying to figure out how do I
protect every citizen in the state how
do I protect every little town the big
cities and all that and eventually you
started realizing where are those
highest risk areas instead of trying to
spread all your resources out like we
were at first we were then able to find
out just really the such as the
african-american community the food
processing prisons
you know nursing homes we were able to
target those things and I think that's
when everything to me started to curve
when everybody started being able to
realize hey here's the real problems
with this and then what creates it well
how do you spread the virus and you know
I think people started realizing hey I
got to stay home I don't need to be out
anymore and I have to be I don't need to
be in crowds I don't need to go to
restaurants work shoulder-to-shoulder
and I think that's
after people started we all started
learning more about it but I think
originally we just didn't have the facts
in place that we needed it looked like
to me governor there have been more than
1,900 cases and eighty more than eighty
deaths since you lifted restrictions on
June 15th right I think those are the
numbers you were asks if you take
responsibility for those deaths and your
response was I don't know that any one
person is responsible for that any more
than anyone else standing out here in
this hallway and it was reported that
you asked the reporter who asked you
that question if she takes
responsibility you have since been I
think it's fair to say very heavily
criticized for your response mostly by
the media and Missouri Democrats do you
want to clarify what you meant there
yeah let me just say this you know I
know on the national level they try to
blame the president they try to blame
the governor for people dying every day
but let me let me go back to the history
of Who I am
I lost a brother in law in the line of
duty as an EMT he got killed in a
terrible accident do I blame the driver
that it was his responsibility because
what happened it was just a terrible
accident you know things are going to
happen in everyday life that you whether
it's cancer whether it's fatalities but
I think to try to say governor do you
feel responsible for everybody dying for
whatever reason is an unreasonable
question to start off with you know III
think it's the I gotcha question that is
what that question was asked for you
know the reality of it is I don't want
anybody to die you know I've lost
officers in the line of duty to sheriff
you know I've had them shot six times
and survived you know and when somebody
asked me that question you know I don't
want any citizen in this state to die I
don't want people to die in the nursing
homes like my mom and dad did but to
kind of try to say well it's your fault
governor because people are dying from a
virus you know to me that's a total
unfair question to ask and try to pin
that on someone like why is any why is
any one person responsible for a virus
or for cancer for any other illness that
you can just say hey it's your fault
peep
or dying I just don't think the normal
person no matter what party you're with
no matter what the political is I don't
think the majority people anybody wants
people to die on when it's not their
time to die however they died understood
governor just a few more New York's
Governor Cuomo said Thursday the
governor's like Ron de santis in Florida
and other red states have played
politics with this virus by reopening
too soon and the rising case numbers
show they are losing this this game what
do you say to something like that yeah
you know for ninety days during the
corona virus I have did nothing but try
to be the best governor I could be in my
state I didn't bring the political side
into this at all you know all everybody
wanted to say red states blue states and
all this stuff the reason I opened the
state of Missouri was because of the
Missouri data I had within my hand it
was put together by infectious disease
doctors that was part of that Advisory
Group across the state the universities
in the state were part of that process
mayors across the state County
Commissioners across the state
hospitalisation down ventilators down
real data is how I made that decision
not a question whether it was a red or
blue state I could care less about that
you know what I wanted to make sure is
when I put people out there there was
going to be some ability for people to
feel safe and I had to have that
information I think we did and we put it
out to the public and explained and
again we explain everyday in our press
briefings the responsibility is going to
come back to social distinct is the
number one thing that we can all do to
protect one another and I say that every
day and will continue to say that so
there's some sort of scientific proof to
say and that's not just as things were
starting to reopen in several states
around Memorial Day George Floyd was
killed and the protesting began mostly
against police you are a former sheriff
are you of the mindset that law
enforcement and police agencies need
substantive reform you know look I think
you have to look at each the individual
cases that happened I think what
happened Minnesota we've seen that the
video on it shouldn't ever happen
I'm a firm believer when you're a police
officer I've wore the uniform for 22
years or more the ban
when you take that oath office you put
that badge on you should always be held
to a higher standard
I don't care where you're at what agency
you're with you should be held to a
higher standard if you don't like being
held to a higher standard you shouldn't
be in the business of law enforcement so
first of all they've got to be
accountable when they make mistakes can
please do better can we figure out ways
to do things very sure you can we all
can in our personal lives you know that
we can figure out ways to do better when
we go look at mistakes that we've made
and the law enforcement has to do that
the bottom line is law and order has to
be out there it's been out there since
the biblical days and it will continue
to be out there there has to be rules
there has to be regulations on society
and law enforcement has to enforce that
and when I say that they have to be
there to protect people also you had you
had to manage a budget as sheriff I mean
could you foresee budgets that maybe do
divert some amount of funding so that a
different group can handle some of those
mental health calls or some of those
social welfare calls it sounds like a
lot of the police over the years have
gotten a little frustrated with their
role as a social worker
yeah well I think even here in Missouri
we were talking about putting social
workers out there to to join up with law
enforcement to answer calls I think
there's other areas that are doing that
so I think when you talk about reform
those are all changes we can make I
think mental health issues sometimes you
know law enforcement officers are not
trained so much in how to handle mental
health cases maybe a preliminary case of
it but I know other police departments
other people around are starting to put
mental health experts in cars social
workers in cars to do that I don't think
there's anything wrong with having those
discussions
Missouri governor Mike Marcin thank you
so much for your time all right thank
you very much
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the untold story
with Martha McCallum the host of the
story on Fox News Channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold stories subscribe and listen now
by going to Fox News podcasts dot-com
subscribe to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts comm and now some good news
with Tanya J powers
this week's good news takes the form of
a birthday wish it's for a special 20
year old named August Auggie as she's
more commonly referred to has become the
oldest known living golden retriever and
she turned the big 200 in April
according to a recent post from the gold
heart golden retrievers rescue she lives
with her owners Jennifer and Steve
header site in Oakland Tennessee they
say Augie had already had two previous
homes before they adopted her when she
was 14 according to the gold hearts
website most golden retrievers live ten
or twelve years and some lived a 15
that's why all geese 20th is a big deal
she recently celebrated with a dog
friendly carrot cake in the shape of a
bone while wearing a bandana that said
it's my birthday and then hanging out
with her Golden Retriever siblings
Sherman Bell and Bruce Jennifer header
site says Augie is still surprisingly
healthy and moves around well once she
gets up and going so happy birthday
Augie and congratulations on your
milestone Tonya J powers Fox News
it's time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind so the FBI
determined there was not a noose hanging
in the garage and NASCAR driver Bubba
Wallace and that's a great thing because
racism is terrible and the country isn't
enough chaos right now without adding to
it seriously if things don't stop pretty
soon mobs will be tearing down statues
all over the country oh wait the FBI
determined the air quotes noose was the
same pull down rope hanging on every
other garage door at the track it seems
like the kind of obvious thing reporters
would investigate before running the
story but to put it in NASCAR terms the
left-wing media is on the wrong track
they suffer from a condition called
REITs ISM meaning if something gets
ratings it's more important to get the
story out than it is to get the story
right and if you don't believe me ask
Jesse Smollett who watch left-wing host
run with his fake attack story for two
days before police threw the challenge
flag but unlike Jesse the liberal media
did not beat themselves up over it nor
will they hold themselves accountable
for this and to be clear I'm not saying
anyone should ignore potential hate
crime in NASCAR but they should have at
least waved the caution flag and sorted
through the facts be sure to check out
Fox across America with me Jimmy Fela
weekdays from noon to three on Fox News
Radio com
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts comm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes